amazon is harming fair competition here
in europe
that is what the european commission
said today when it filed
anti-trust charges against amazon it
accuses the e-commerce giant of
attempting to gain an unfair advantage
over
sellers on its platform the commission
says amazon collects
non-public data from sellers and
consumers and uses that data
to leverage its dominance in its two
biggest
european markets france and germany the
european union started looking into
amazon back in 2018 amazon faces a
possible fine of
up to 10 percent of its annual worldwide
revenue
that could amount to billions of dollars
the company
has rejected the accusations
here is what the eu commission executive
vice president said today about
amazon our concern is not about
amazon retail about the insights that
amazon
retails has into the sensitive business
data of one
particular seller rather
they are about the insights that amazon
retail has about the
accumulated business data of more than
800 000
active sellers in the european union
covering more than a billion
uh products in other words this is the
case
about big data we have therefore come to
the preliminary conclusion
that the use of these data allows amazon
to focus on the sale
of the best selling products and this
martial
marginalizes third-party sellers and
caps
their ability to grow so are consumers
getting a bad deal when they buy or sell
on amazon
well let's pose that question tonight to
augustine
he is with the european consumer
organization beuc which lobbies for
consumer interest
and protection at the european union
it's good to have you on the show i hope
i got your
your name right mr rain is that correct
yes that's correct good evening good
evening do you agree with the european
commission
is amazon hurting competition and
is the consumer paying for it
as consumer organizations we are equally
concerned that amazon could be using
this commercially
sensitive information it collects in its
platform to unfairly influence
consumers to favor amazon on products
and here we're talking
about sensitive information that could
range
from the number of orders and ship units
of products the seller's revenues on the
marketplace the number of visits
to sellers offers data relating to
shipping
or to the seller's past performance so
we're talking about the substantive
amount of
data executive as president the stagger
mentioned and these practices might end
up harming consumers in the medium in
the long term
by favoring its own products and making
it
harder for sellers to compete amazon
could be reducing consumer choice of
online products and sellers and in the
long run even increasing prices
um consumers have to pay due to the to
the lack of competition so we are
talking about um
an extremely important case i i know
that when you use
amazon it is true the the independent
sellers the offers that they make it's
always in smaller print
and amazon doesn't really make it
obvious to you when you're looking at
their page
but what would you say to those sellers
who would argue
that there is no other platform that is
going to give them exposure
to such a large customer base as amazon
well that's exactly the the the problem
that we are we are facing and the
on the retailers are are facing because
there are no other options so they have
to accept
the conditions imposed by um by amazon
basically there is a
great degree of dependency and if we
think about the the current pandemic
and when shops have to close their
their doors due to the different
confinement
and lockdown measures taken by by
different member states
consumer have to go and buy online and
consumers were rushed into to amazon so
basically
retailers were depending heavily on on
amazon to reach out customers
so what do you want what would you like
to see amazon do
um if if they were willing to do
whatever you said in order to get rid of
this anti-trust suit
what would they have to do
well and first of all they would have to
address the specific concerns and
antitrust investigation takes time um
and we will be able to assess in detail
the
scope of the of the of the harm and the
effects of this of these practices
so certainly um if amazon
will like to address these these
concerns they will have to
discuss how to deal with these data
practices with the commissions in a way
that um they don't get an
anti-competitive advantage by gaining
this
data and the way that of course they use
it vis-a-vis the
retailers mr maynard i've got about 30
seconds here just wanted to get your
thought
it's about we see the european union um
you know taking
issue with google for example and now
with amazon
is the consumer in the european union
enjoying
the in your opinion the best protection
that it can get anywhere on the globe
as consumers in the european union we
are
in a privileged position compared to
consumers in other parts of the world
and not only regarding competition
long-conditional enforcement but also
consumer laws data protection laws
the problem however is that we are
talking about global companies
so these situations and this problem
need to be tackled globally
so we also um depend to a certain extent
on other jurisdiction actually to take
in
um action against against these
companies that's a good
that's a very good point i mean because
this size matters with companies
like this augustine reyna with the
european consumer
organization b e u c mr raider we
appreciate your time and your insights
tonight thank you
thank you very much have a nice evening